[Music]
loving other people starts with loving
ourselves and accepting ourselves
and i know many of you have struggled
with this
and i draw upon your strength and your
support
in ways that you will never know
and i am here today because i am gay
and because
the vice president of america wishes i
didn't have the love with my wife
he wanted to ban that in indiana
he believes in conversion therapy
[Music]
he has hurt lgbtq people so badly as the
government of indiana
for example still in a lot of states
lgbt people can be
fired for just being gay or for just
being trans
that's totally legal i mean how do you
feel about that that just doesn't sound
very american to me
you know at the end of the day
what we should not be doing is
persecuting people
who follow their faith like i'll give an
example one of the one of the couples
that's going to be featured tonight what
about the question about lgbt people
all right